this is a production of Cornell
University
hi everyone welcome again to the 2023
hemp webinar series once again your
hosts your PhD student a company with
Tony baracco corner alunda has been
helping me organize this and put
together all the theater platform along
with Gemma
lastly I just want to remind everyone
that this webinar is going to be a
component of a larger project which is
the developmental educational modules
that will be feel available on the
Cornell website this module or each of
the eight modules will have the recorder
webinar an instructional slide deck and
a set of high impact papers respected to
each subject in this case would be
hempest for example
and also remind uh to remind you and
remind others that
this webinar as well as future and past
webinars will be available on the
Cornell sips YouTube channel if you're
interested in re-watching them or
sharing them with somebody else so with
that it is my pleasure to introduce Dr
Kelly Britt she's a postdoctoral scholar
affiliated
the University of California Riverside
in the department of Entomology I do not
want to extend introduction because I'm
sure that you like most of the time to
cover her content
uh and I just want to say that her talk
is going to be on arthropod past higher
nominal hemp so without further Ado
please Dr Brit take it away
thanks Luis well yeah thanks for the
introduction and thanks for the
invitation to be here
um I really appreciate the opportunity
to share
what I've gathered so far over several
years of studying insect and might pests
in hemp or better known as arthropods
um before we jump in I wanted to put my
email address here if you have questions
or comments or anything to share about
anything that I cover today feel free to
reach out I always like talking about
this work and I'm really happy to help
if you need it in any way that I can
um also really briefly there's a lot to
cover but I just wanted to tell you who
I am and my experience in this realm of
work
um I'm Katie I finished I earned my PhD
in entomology from Virginia Tech just
over two years ago the focus of that
work was insect in my Pest Management in
him
started that in 2017 when hemp was
really really new wrapped up in 2021
after finishing that degree I came out
to California
um and have been doing a postdoc with UC
Riverside focused on the same type of
work
um and as Louise said I'm affiliated
with UC Riverside but I'm not in
Southern California I'm located at an
off-campus research station
um in the Central Valley just outside of
Fresno so enough about that I'm gonna
Jump Right In I have so many things to
cover today
um hopefully it won't go over time but
yeah let's get started so again I'm
covering arthropods associated with hemp
this focuses on insects and mites
um the bulk of what I've thought to tell
you about are pest species but it's
worth noting that it's not just pests
arthropods that are associated with hemp
or cannabis um
you know if you walk through a field
with an outdoor field or an indoor
production system you're going to see an
abundance of species a lot of those are
bad guys some of those are good guys
some of those are just passing through
um as in occasional theaters or
transient species
sometimes they're attracted to hemp
because it's there it's an available
food source they might try to feed on it
before they find that they don't like it
or want to move on or they see something
in the hemp that they're attracted to
um and they could be attracted to
another species more than the crop
itself so again it's worth noting that
you're going to see a lot of insect and
Mite activity but not all of it is bad
um but we're going to focus on some of
the bad ones today so the first and
foremost that I want to talk about is
corn ear worm I always say this is not
an if pest it's a win if you're growing
a crop Outdoors you're going to see this
and your crop is likely to be damaged
from it
um I've I've tried to put this beginning
slide on the key pest that I'm going to
discuss today so I've got the common
name of Pop along with the scientific
name where it's found whether it's a
generalist or a specialist
whether you can find it indoor or
outdoor and the likelihood of
encountering this pest in your operation
so this is a pest that's found pretty
much everywhere it's found Outdoors only
in rare situations can it be found
indoors
um and that's usually because it came in
on some harvested material and I say
likelihood of encounter this is pretty
certain if you're producing a crop
Outdoors so again it's a key Pest of
hemp um I think
the number one pest that may differ
based on the system that you're
producing in but
I always stick by the fact that this is
pretty much the number one best of him
this is what it looks like it's a
caterpillar the adult stage is a moth
it's a pretty drab colored tan moth
um
on the the photo on the left you can see
where she's actually laying eggs in a
hemp plant and on the right has some
photos of the actual eggs they're really
really tiny they're visible to the naked
eye but they're difficult to see just
because this tiny egg can really blend
in with the rest of the plant material
um but they are visible like I said
um here's some more photos you know they
can vary in size as they move and
develop throughout the plant they can
differ in coloration as well as location
throughout the plant
um larval coloration in particular can
vary most of the caterpillars that you
see in hemp are going to be a bright
green but again that depends sometimes
they can be darker in color they can be
yellow they can be pink black brown
um quite a spectrum
so they're really attracted to hemp when
it begins to flower as our most
arthropods that we cover today they're
attracted to and they feed from the
inflorescence portion of the crop which
is the attractive portion once the
inflorine inflorescences start to form
moths female moths are active and they
may begin laying eggs on the crop at
this time
um so it can be tricky to find them
sometimes because they'll Nestle in
Plants as you can see in the photo on
the left and in addition to chewing Bud
structures they can just chew all
throughout the plant sometimes they'll
feed from leaves but it's more commonly
stems and Bud material
their chewing can really damage the
Integrity of the stem so you see the
feeding wound in the middle of this
photo
um basically the rest of the plant
material that's attached to where this
wound is is likely going to die so it's
going to rot and create this brown
coloration and just end up with rotted
material that you can't really do
anything with and it's just making your
your bud material ugly and taking away
some material that you would Harvest so
again these feeding injuries can lead to
what we call Bud rot
um sometimes it can come from just the
stem bean clip and that plant material
just straight up dying off but I think
more commonly what is happening is that
this caterpillar is coming in feeding on
the plant and creating these wounds and
pathogens that exist in the environment
are able to get in Via these feeding
wounds which ends up causing rotted
material in the plant
so rot I think you know it's
it's concentrated in these Bud portions
it's typically more towards the top of
the plant but not always
um it can be present anywhere there is
blood material and like I was saying
earlier it's just really undesirable if
you're trying to harvest this to sell it
as a raw material you know there's going
to be speckled spots of rot throughout
it and it's really highly undesirable
um they're frass
um also known as insect poop can also be
an additional contaminant these photos
are from my time in Virginia which is a
more humid climate than the west where
I'm at now but you know pathogens are a
major concern and like I've stated in
any time there's feeding wounds these
pathogens can get in
um it's just it's gross it's really
undesirable you don't want them anywhere
near the plant really but they're going
to be there more photos where the
caterpillar has just eaten and moved
throughout the plant and deposited its
grass along the way it's yucky it's
gross you really don't want to see this
um so what do we know about this Pest
and what has field research told us
um so this is published in Open Access
publication through the Journal of
integrated Pest Management there's a
screenshot of the article below that you
want to access it
um
you know the the photo of the trap on
the right this is an adult mock or an
earworm trap this is used in other type
of crop systems like soybeans and corn
where corn ear worm is also a pest you
know it'd be really great if we could
use these in hemp
um you can definitely use these traps in
hemp um to alert you that moths are
active and circulating around the field
but unfortunately the number of moths
that are caught in traps doesn't seem to
correlate with larval abundance at the
sites where we've conducted studies
um so
again pheromone traps can let you know
that moths are active and potentially
depositing eggs on the crop but it's
really not always a reliable predictor
of larval presence in the crop that
really comes from you scouting it and
knowing what's going on in your crop
as far as Court earworm management this
is going to differ based on where you're
located and what typical pesticide rules
are based on where you live and where
you produce your crop but something I at
least want to draw your particular
attention to is a group of insecticides
that are called nucleopolyhedral viruses
the big word um you could use npv for
short
um I've done some studies with these
particularly in Virginia and you know
it's not a Silver Bullet by any means
but it is at least an option that I
think
um I want you to know about you know the
only thing with using these products
timing is really important you've got to
Target really small caterpillars so
again this comes from scouting knowing
that the pest is in your field you can
apply an insecticide at the correct time
and get greater efficacy
um its only target is corn ear worms so
it's safe for non-targets unlike BT or
other types of biopesticides which may
attack more species
so what it looks like when corn ear worm
larvae are infected by this virus they
kind of just look melted and kind of
snotty like hanging on the bud material
of the plant so it looks really gross
but it's a good sign it means the
insecticide is working
additionally larvae will migrate to the
top portion of the plant as they die and
as they are dying as their body breaks
down viral particles will spread
throughout the field
um so it's just letting you know that
this type of insecticide exists and I
think it's a decent option for a corner
management based on what we know at this
point
so that was a lot of information about
one pest but to wrap this section up you
know this is a very damaging Pest and
it's going to remain a damaging pest in
hemp um under outdoor production for the
foreseeable future
the best option for management at this
time is to remain diligent Scout as
often as you can and initiate control
measures whatever you decide to do at
the first appearance of larvae because
no matter what you do everything works
better with smaller larvae
um of the allowable options the virus
insecticides may offer the highest level
of earworm suppression at this point but
you know we need more research which is
the theme for everything that I'll talk
about today in any conversation you
would have with me about this topic we
need more work we need more work across
more locations so that we know what's
going on in different regions across the
country
so that's all for corn earworm
next Target is cannabis aphid so the
scientific name is bored on cannabis the
range as far as I know it's everywhere
anywhere that you would grow hemp or
cannabis you're likely to see this
insect it's a specialist meaning that it
exclusively feeds from hemp or cannabis
and this can be found in indoor or
outdoor crops likelihood of encounter I
say probable just because it's a
specialist so it's highly likely that
you'll see it
um so like I've said uh Cannabis sativa
is the only plant species in which this
species will feed from it is a
specialist so it you know planting other
crops to try and distract this
particular aphid won't really work here
um this aphid is typically light green
maybe light yellow kind of clear in
coloration it can have wings it cannot
have wings it can be a smaller aphid it
can be a larger aphid you name it you
might see it as cannabis aphid
um there is you know pretty good
potential for parasitism of this aphid
by parasitoid wasps
and more research is being done with
these particular wasps to figure out
what kind of Target is best
so when I give a shout out to Andrea
garfinkel from Oregon CBD for this photo
this is a really helpful image that kind
of shows a key identification
characteristic of this aphid it has
these really pronounced nodules on the
um on its head capsule which if you look
at this under a microscope and you see
these little horn projections you're
gonna know that it's cannabis aphid that
you have
um asexual reproduction is common for
this insect meaning that the female
gives live birth to identical Offspring
um in addition to these non-winged forms
uh reproductive or winged forms can
develop as well you can kind of see
these winged forms Outdoors or in indoor
situations where Avid populations are
pretty dense
so unfortunately for management females
can produce several Offspring per day so
populations can quickly Skyrocket to
high numbers in a very short amount of
time
if you're producing outdoors and you see
this insect outdoor populations are
highest later in the season kind of
close to harvest and just reiterating
again that since this insect produce
reproduces primarily asexually
populations can increase very quickly
this insect can be found all throughout
the plant so that includes leaves stems
and Bud material there you'd see them a
lot on stems and typically on the
underside of weeds like in this photo
um a risk with this insect is that as it
moves through the plant and feeds it
excretes the substance called honeydew
which is a really sticky substance and
honeydew can lead to [__] mold
formation which is kind of the black
looking stuff on the leaves and the
photos in addition as the aphid molts
and grows it sheds exoskeletons and
these can get caught in the city mold
which is just really really gross and
not pretty to look at and it leads you
with a sticky plant in addition to the
you know the normal stickiness of him
um
something that we see from aphids and
other plants if you look at the photo on
the top right you can sometimes see
yellowing Leaf curling and wilting
resulting from aphid feeding this isn't
typically
at least in my experience not what we've
seen with cannabis aphid it can
definitely still cause some yellowing
and some slight Leaf curling but you
know the photo on the left the damage
from this aphid isn't as bad as what you
see a damage that you see from aphids
and other crops
again just showing some photos it can
cause this sticky coating on Plants due
to the Honeydew
and again you can see the populations in
these photos have quickly gotten out of
hand this is the really bad case of
management
same here really bad situation with
um just pointing out again that plants
can be filled with aphids that still
retain their Vigor
um you definitely don't want to see this
this is a bad lapse in judgment here
where management was not taken early
enough at all and the plants are just
sticky and filled with
um aphids and cast skins and just not
not very good
um yet again more cases of bad
management so if you're producing
Outdoors it's really important that you
get rid of any leftover plant material
in the field at the end of season just
because you know we're not sure how
you know what the cold tolerance of this
insect is but you know material left and
Fields can help sustain populations
between seasons
additionally it's a good thing natural
enemies can Aid management
you typically see lady beetles feeding
on this aphid quite a lot outdoors and
there are other things like assassin
bugs banzel bugs and then
um Green Lace means that can help manage
populations
so as far as management strategies I
can't say enough how important it is to
scout Outdoors make sure you're removing
crop material at the season end and you
know kind of let natural enemies do
their thing they'll help you with
management indoors you really want to
inspect any kind of plant material prior
to introducing it into your operation
make sure it's clean as you're starting
um you can employ natural enemies as
well if you choose to use insecticides
consider using things like soaps
insecticidal soaps neem oil azodiractin
or other biological products that are
legal in the state where you're
producing I would suggest using
pyrethrins as a last resort just because
these can kill off natural enemies as
well
moving on
oh okay next up is two spotted spider
mite so this is found pretty much
everywhere as well it's a generalist
pest that can be it's primarily present
in indoor environments but it can be
outdoors as well in in certain ranges
likelihood of encounter it's possible
it's not always a given that you're
going to see this one
so like I said it's a common pest
indoors no matter what you're producing
less frequently encountered Outdoors but
it can be common in drier or more Airy
climates like the western United States
um it's big enough that you can see it
with the naked eye you don't need
microscopy for it and it is a Mite so it
has eight legs
um two spotted spider mites have these
needle-like piercing sucking mouth parts
so as they feed on hemp plants they'll
cause the stippling on leaves which
leaves these kind of dotted looking
appearances which is very typical of
goose potted spider feeding
webbing is really common where
populations are dense these webs that
they form are actively are actual
actually a protective measure to kind of
keep them safe Under the Umbrella of
this webbing so that they can continue
reproducing and expanding their
populations
um you can see as well just the kind of
dirty looking appearance in both of
these photos where there's significance
of mites
um just two videos to show you
how how it looks when their populations
are really dense
um this is shared from a grower in
California
um this is a pretty dense population you
can see all the little mites moving
around the video on the left the video
on the right you can see
um the webbing on the this kind of
grouping of plants again it's you
um definitely want to implement some
type of management before it gets to
this point
um so what are some strategies for
management again scouting is is super
important it's important to inspect
plants prior to introducing them and
anywhere that you see an outbreak maybe
try to you know Implement some form of
management luckily due to data on this
Pest and other types of greenhouse
production systems we know that natural
enemies work really well one of the
particular ones is phytoceola or
stimulus there are definitely others I
think this is just a really common one
other species of predatory mites can Aid
management as well my new pirate bugs
are really good for management here if
you use pesticides insecticidal soaps or
Oils will work will work really well
all right so next is hemp russet Mite
this is another specialist similar to
the Cannabis aphid it only feeds from
Cannabis sativa crops
um in my experience I've seen it indoors
and Outdoors the likelihood of encounter
I say possible I'll talk about this as
we move through this section but I think
the most common situation here is that
you get plant material or cuttings from
an outside Source the that material
comes already partially infested with
these mites and they're really really
difficult to manage once you have them
in your environment
so these mites are very small unlike the
two-spotted spider mite you can't see
them with the naked eye this is also a
different type of Mite it's in the I
didn't note this on the last slide but
it's in a different family called
ariophiety these are very very small
they only have four legs they use their
four little legs to kind of pinch into
the plant and hold themselves in place
um
you really need microscopy or in some
cases if you have a really strong hand
lens that might work to help confirm
presence but I always highly recommend
microscopes or
some kind of something where you can see
the plant material
up really close
um it's you can see this in the photo on
the top left the scale here is half a
millimeter and they're even smaller than
that so for some kind of idea of scale
um if you're on the East Coast it's
after lunch if you're on the west coast
it's launch time or just before
um this is kind of what the mites can
look like under the microscope
um not zoomed in too much but I always
tell Growers they look like it's like
you shredded parmesan cheese or you
sprinkled something on your pasta um
not to ruin your appetite but hopefully
that will help you remember what they
what they look like again they're super
tiny these are photos of some aphids
under the microscope and where I have
the arrows pointed those are all little
russet mites that got caught in the
aphid in the process of doing this
research project so just for scale
they're really really small
um mites prefer to invest developing
buds so developing or developed parts of
the plant material their feeding can
reduce the size and quality of future
buds as the plant grows and develops
um where the Mite has fed in these new
and developing areas there's usually a
kind of just dirty or gray appearance
where they've fed
Um this can this can happen from you
know they're feeding from the surface of
the leaf they're getting rid of some of
the chlorophyll and the leaves so it
just looks gray and drab and just sickly
and dirty overall
as I've said their feeding injury can
lead to decreased Bud density this was
from an indoor hemp facility in Virginia
they had a massive infestation of hemp
russet mites they managed to salvage the
plants to an extent I mean this isn't a
super attractive looking plant at this
point but you know it at least there's
something there but you can see where
the density of the buds are drastically
decreased it's really patchy and not
super uniform
likely other things going on here as
well but the key infestation with him
for us at night
like I've said it can be a problem both
indoors and out issues can really arise
from infested transplants this is in a
field setting
um this one plant was really
under the pressure of hemp breasted
mites the ones around it weren't as bad
um you know also given these mites are
so small they can kind of easily
disperse on wind it just depends on the
environment and what what the weather is
like basically here you know that didn't
really happen the population stayed
pretty isolated but it's it's worth
knowing how small they are and how
easily they can move if wind comes sorry
wind comes through
as I've said earlier too with lots of
mites the plant material can look dirty
or Dusty
um
it's this is just a really dense
population of impressive mites the one
on the right it looks like it could be
it could have been dip in dirt or
something you know same for the photo on
the top left
um but if you had a microscope and were
able to zoom in this is actually what
you'd see a pretty heavy abundance of
impressive mites so kind of gross
um I I want to point this out too I
think earlier on one of the one of the
key
thoughts about russet might feeding an
injury on hemp and cannabis or marijuana
plants was that you know the most
typical symptom was this Leaf curling
um that's definitely not always the case
some cultivars will react in this way
but not all so a good example is the
photo on the left mites were detected on
the photo on the right there's the curl
and mites were not detected
here again mites were not detected on
these plants
and here this is leaves curling down
mites were detected here but you know
this is not always the case so the what
I'm really trying to tell you here is
that leaf curling is a lot of times just
kind of a genetic response to some
source of stress whether on the plant or
whether it's environmental so Leaf
curling is not always indicative of a
hempress at my infestation but the key
is that you should you know really
invest in a microscope if this is a crop
that you're planning to produce long
term because it can save you from these
infestations
um again scouting is really important
you know if you're bringing material
indoors make sure you're inspecting this
plant prior to introducing it into your
environment it's worth coordinating off
a section as well or kind of you know
quarantining this plant material before
it's introduced to the rest of the
operation just in case you've got you
know some mites even a small population
could increase pretty quickly
um as far as other management tactics
natural enemies we don't know of any at
this point or at least ones that would
Target this might are not commercially
produced and available when it comes to
pesticides always check to see what the
rules and regulations are where you live
and where you produce your crop but data
that we've seen so far it seems like
oils and sulfur work the best
um I did not put the publication in this
section but I do have a published trial
looking at impressive management it's in
the journal arthropod management tests
and it's open access so it can search
for it you'll be able to find it
All Right Moving On Again uh next up is
beat wee popper and I've kind of grouped
other Leaf hoppers in here as well
um this specific Leaf Hopper the Beet
Leaf Hopper is present only in the
Western United States
um but it's a big problem so I've I've
included it in this presentation it's a
generalist species pimp or cannabis or
marijuana is not its preferred plant at
all but since outdoor production has
increased over the past few years we've
definitely seen a lot of injury from
this insect
um your risk level I think it's very
likely that you'll encounter this
particularly and only particularly if
you're in the Western United States
um so there's a photo of it on the top
and a photo of it here it's a pretty
non-descript looking Leaf Hopper
um if you see Leaf hoppers on your plant
you should you know at least note that
they're there
um these are photos that I got from
punya nachapa she is a professor at
Colorado State University she's done a
lot of work with insect virus
interactions and done a lot of work with
this species in particular and so this
is a publication from her group and
these are all symptoms that resulted
from beet Leaf Hopper
or I'm sorry beat curly top virus
um in the field which is the virus that
this Leaf Opera causes so you can see
things like fasciation yellowing and
Hopper burn Distortion of leaves and
even Leaf curls like I was saying with
russet my it's not always just a symptom
of rust it might it's a greater
indicator of some type of stress to the
plant overall
um I think the key one of the key
symptoms to this virus is this
Distortion and kind of leaf curling as a
scientist it's really cool and really
pretty to see but as a grower this is
not good to see at all
um the photo on the bottom left you can
see how this plant is just a little more
yellowed overall it's not this deep
Healthy Green like you want to see and
there's Hopper burn on the edges of
these leaves
these photos were taken by me in
California this was in California this
past summer as well along the coast this
was
I thought some pretty drastic symptoms
of beat curly top virus um again just
reiterating what this and what this can
do and what type of symptoms it can
cause in the plant
um also from along the coast this year
you know by the end of the season these
plants are still alive and they had Buds
and stuff but they just didn't look as
good as the plants that didn't get this
virus in the first place
um it's just weird you know we're still
learning about this and we know that
it's causing yield loss we just haven't
been able to quantify how much your loss
it's pausing just yet
so in addition to beat Leaf Hopper there
are all all kinds of leaf poppers found
throughout hemp these are photos taken
of specimens we've collected from a
survey in California over the past two
years
um still really unsure of what they're
all doing and which ones are most the
biggest risk for us but you know beat
Leaf poppers one you really gotta watch
out for here's what the insect looks
like they're really small insects they
move really quickly the adult is on the
left nymph is on the right the nymph
just doesn't have wings so it kind of
scurries and walks along the leaf where
the adult can just pop and fly away and
get out of your way really quick
um these are photos from a friend and
colleague in the midwest so this is not
beat Leaf Hopper but again it's
reiterating these symptoms that leaf
poppers can cause to plants
um this yellowing Distortion and this
general just Hopper burn on the edge of
leaves so it's it's just a weird thing
that it causes and like I've said it's
causing yield loss we just haven't been
able to quantify it yet
so management strategies here are pretty
tough
um in other crop systems you know
there's been research done over years
and years we know the resistant
varieties or resistant cultivars and
hemp and marijuana cannabis we don't
know that at this time another strategy
in other crops is seed treatments um
we are not there for him we likely will
not be there for many years to come
so not an option for us right now either
when it comes to pesticides this can be
really challenging
um due to the just the general nature of
this insect you know like I showed you
the insect is really small it moves hops
around pops on and off of the plants
really quickly
um all it takes is them landing on the
plant feeding and they can transmit the
virus very quickly so they don't have to
live on it they don't have to sit on it
for hours at a time you know they're
there they feed and they're gone that's
how quickly the virus can get to a plant
and once the virus is in it it's it's
not going to change
um so with that said you know I don't
know that pesticides are even the best
option just due to the nature of the
insect associated with the crop
um an even if insecticides were an
option I think the conventional products
are the ones that would work better
something like a systemic insecticide
but
that's not going to exist in hemp um now
or probably for the foreseeable future
so it's a challenge but research is
ongoing
um the last key species that I want to
talk about is rice root aphid this is
one we've seen and learned a little bit
more about over the past couple of years
um I think this is an everywhere pest as
well it's a generalist meaning that it's
not specifically targeting Cannabis
sativa crops
um I think it can exist in crop systems
Outdoors but the primary
concern is in indoor production and risk
level I've put moderate
you know this risk level that I've put
on here is just my kind of General view
of the problem and I've put it at
moderate because if you have it it's
likely to be an issue
um but if you can maintain good
sanitation you know you may not end up
seeing it
this has been a challenging species to
study just the summer 2022 I tried
several times to get a colony of these
started to try and do something with
research they wouldn't cooperate so it's
and that's the um sentiment I've heard
from other colleagues across the country
that it's difficult to get these
established to try and do further
research on so as the name suggests
they're primarily found in Roots as you
can see in the two photos on the left
but uh fairly recent paper from Whitney
Crenshaw and Suzanne Wainwright Evans
and in conversations with Suzanne we've
learned that you know just because it's
primarily a root aphid doesn't mean it's
always in The Roots it can sometimes be
seen on leaves and stems and feeding
more throughout the plant
um I still the primary region we're
concern is the root so
here's another video from a grower I
know this it's kind of blurry it's
moving kind of quickly but if you focus
on the the green areas in the middle or
top portion of the video you can see
um where these aphids are concentrated
along the roots of a plant
um so as the name suggests they really
like the roots here again they are found
in the soil area of plants
so
just alone the fact that it's a root
pest makes it a huge challenge you know
scouting is always important it's
important here but you know my first
instinct is not always to check the
roots if the plant looks like it's
dwindling I
and assume many others might think that
it's something else before assuming that
it could be rice root aphid
um
as far as insecticides go
um I think root drenches are the way to
go but again I you know I'm saying this
with Extreme Caution and I've got the
second bullet point on the slide kind of
emphasizing that this is highly
dependent on local state local and state
regulations and it's highly dependent on
label language on the product that
you're using this is likely not allowed
in a lot of locations but it's I guess
information that we know from seeing
this pest in other types of crops where
insecticide use like this would be
allowed so this one's a challenge but I
think it's a point to um
hope you remember that sometimes there's
stuff happening
um below the soil you know there's
things in The Roots which is not always
your first instinct when you're Scouting
For pests
so now for the rest of the PowerPoint
I've got some just kind of occasional
species that I've seen
um Group by chewing insects piercing
sucking insects and then root pests
these are things that are not that big
of a problem but they're things that
you'll likely see either indoors or
Outdoors so I just wanted to share some
information and draw your attention to
whether they're a concern or not
so for the chewing group on this side
I've just got the photo of yellow
striped army worm there are all kinds of
species of caterpillars that are going
to be present in hemp and chew from
leaves or sometimes stems and sometimes
buds
um I think most typically these other
species are found feeding on leaves in
some certain or extreme conditions they
can be found feeding from Bud material
but most likely going to be concentrated
on leaves these are things like army
worms cut worms and wooly bears
um
an application of BT would help these um
would help knock these back you know I
didn't really recommend BT for corn
earworm just because we see a lot of
resistance in outdoor situations
um but for other caterpillars BT seems
to work a little bit better
there are going to be things like
grasshoppers too depending on your
location and depending on the
infestation level or the type of crops
surrounding your hemp crop these can be
a great risk or they can be kind of a
lower risk
in extreme conditions you know they'll
chew stems and cause plants to topple
over I think mature young plants are
more vulnerable to grasshoppers than
older or mature plants but you know it's
it's worth knowing about I think these
can be an extreme concern in rangeland
areas or
areas where there's more open area like
you would typically see in the Western
United States these can be a challenge
too because any insecticide that would
likely work to manage a grasshopper
really well is likely not allowed in him
um and the problem with Biologicals and
the products that are allowed in hemp is
that you know there may not be as much
of a residual or persistent effect with
that particular insecticide
um so it's not going to Aid the problem
super well
um there are lots of beetles these are
typically feeding from leaves one in
particular
um the one in the middle Southern corn
root worm or cucumber Beetle and other
types of crops these can transmit
bacterial infections I've not seen
anything like that happening in hemp yet
so I not too worried about it right now
again they typically feed from Leaf area
which loss of leaf surface area has not
been
of concern so far I've never seen any
resulting yield loss or crop injury just
from Leaf feeding
we've also got flea beetles
um these come and go you'll sometimes
you see them sometimes you won't they
move really quickly like the leaf
Hoppers their name is flea beetles so
they can hop very quickly from plant to
plant the typical type of crop injury
here again is focused in the leaves but
you can kind of see it on the lower
portions of the photo on the left and
then the photo on the bottom right they
cause this particular thing called shot
hold damage so it looks like you know if
um it's like a spray of little holes in
the leaves but again loss of leaf
surface area hasn't led to any type of
plant damage or yield boss that we've
seen so far
other groups are scarab beetles
um this is a I think one of the more
extreme cases of beetle feeding on a
plant this was from one of my PhD
committee members
um just on a localized portion of the
plant they kind of skeletonized this
Leaf section and even with this you know
intense Leaf loss
um the plant was fine it recovered super
well
same situation here this was sent from a
grower in North Carolina
um
considerable portions of the leaf
surface area can be removed and nothing
really happens so you know it's good to
be on the lookout it's good to know that
this is happening but I wouldn't freak
out too much if you see this happening
next is piercing sucking insects so you
know we've got other aphids
um like potato aphid green peach aphid
melon and melon or cotton aphid
um it's I think it's the similar case to
cannabis aphid they can feed they can
extract nutrients from the plant but
it's not really harming it like you
would see in a typical type of
Horticultural crop so either whether
it's cannabis aphid or other aphid
species you'll see them
I you know manage them if they get to
considerable numbers but I wouldn't
freak out about these other aphid
species too much
other groups are stink bugs they're
different types of stink bugs or
different species of stink bugs that you
can see in Plants
um also did not share the publication
here but one of my PhD research
objectives was looking at stink bugs in
hemp and based on a study that we did
we caged stink bugs on buds of plants
and didn't see any type of negative
impact to the crop from stink bug
presence or feeding
um so just showing photos of stink bugs
in the plants not a cause for concern in
my opinion
same for ligus bugs this one could cause
some anxiety just because you know
furnished plant bug is a highly
injurious pain injurious pest in crops
like cotton it can really reduce yields
in Cotton but have not seen anything
like that in hemp either in my
experience East Coast and West Coast
this insect can be present in crops from
planting all the way to harvest but I've
never seen any kind of impact that all
from their feeding so that's good news
for now but it's definitely something to
remain on the lookout for
another group are chinch bugs same story
here no negative impact we really more
often see these concentrated on grain or
seed variety hemp they really like
feeding from seeds but even they are no
noticeable impact to seeds or seed
Harvest
white flies
um these are prevalent pretty much
throughout the US I've seen more of them
during my time on the west coast but
even in very dense populations I've not
seen any kind of you know really
negative impact to the plant
um the plant seems to do pretty fine
with the presence of these there is
always concern that there could be risk
of virus or pathogen transmission but
to date have not seen that occurring
thrips similar story here there could be
concern with these because they can
transmit pathogens or viruses not seeing
that be a problem
um
I think these can be a reason for
concern but
to my knowledge and given my experience
I've not seen a crop suffer from grip
speeding or injury
um just more close photos of what they
look like adult is on the left a more
juvenile version is on the right and
then here's what the adults look like
they're really really small so this is a
super zoomed in photo
um they have mouth Parts called rasping
sucking mouth part sounds really extreme
they can cause the stippling appearance
on leaves as well kind of kind of
similar to spider mite feeding but not
exactly the same
another might is the broad might I
unfortunately haven't seen this in hemp
or marijuana or cannabis too much but um
it's it's something that can happen I've
included this photo it's a it was a
retroactive realization but it seemed
like this plant and an indoor growing
environment may have had a little bit of
broad night damage
um but not not a ton of bad stuff going
on but I don't know a lot about this one
unfortunately but it's worth noting that
it has been reported from pimp and
cannabis crops
um next group are root pests other
things are fungus gnats you know this
um I'm not saying that damage is exactly
like that from rice from Rice root aphid
but it's at least worth having on your
radar
um these usually arise from improper
sanitation or kind of really wet soil
plants it's just another one to kind of
think about because you know we don't
always think to inspect the roots first
thing but there can be stuff going on in
The Roots
another group are fire ants so this is
from a colleague in the Southeast in
Alabama
these can be a really big problem for
outdoor crops down there
um you know in addition to just the risk
that they pose by being in the field to
to you as a grower or a worker walking
through this field
um this was this was kind of a surprise
to learn about that they really Target
roots and stem portions of plants and
can really cause damage in young plants
so young plants are the concern here
they'll feed from them and can cause a
lot of plant loss
um another kind of surprise pest was
termites you know if you recall hemp has
kind of a Woody stem so this kind of
makes sense in all the cases and
situations where I've seen or heard
about termite damage there's always been
some kind of bed or decaying a rotting
log or tree in the presence of the field
so this is what led the termite damage
in him
another group was wire worms this is
another root pest you aren't really
going to be aware that this is present
in a field until it's too late these
worms exist in the soil and once Roots
start to grow in the soil they'll feed
from the roots and can Farm plants in
that way so this is a a pest that you
have to look for proactively in outdoor
environments
another is leaf miners I've seen a lot
of these
um on both coasts and you know they they
make pretty art for you I haven't seen
any kind of negative impact other than
that
um one of the last ones to talk about is
Eurasian hemp water there's not a lot
um I guess this is one of the more
historically reported pests from the era
of fiber hemp production in the early
United or sorry in the early era of hemp
production in the United States
um
it's a borer as the name suggests so it
chews its way into the lower portion of
the stem and bores its way up through
the stem it has this really as a larva
it has this really distinct orange or
pink coloration as an adult The Moth is
really small and it has this kind of
face looking
um Arrangement on its wings
um this I think is more common in the
midwest or areas where there was
historical hemp production and where
there still may be what we call feral
hemp hemp that just grows wildly this
you're more likely to see it there I
haven't really seen it be a problem in
Virginia or California in my experience
thus far but it's definitely one to know
about
now in the last one I wanted to talk
about is another type of historical pest
the European corn borer
um this one as well bores into the stem
of crops I was really really kind of
worried about this as a pest until I saw
it firsthand in the field a few years
ago
um it definitely bores into plants this
was a cannabinoid hemp plant where all
these photos came from but you know it
it might have harmed a little section of
the plant but it didn't knock out the
whole plant entirely so it's still one
to watch for and if you see holes on the
plant or this kind of sawdust looking
appearance like in the um bottom middle
photo it could indicate that there's
some type of boring situation happening
but it's um not not the most common and
you know for European corn borer and
Eurasian hemp borer this is not
don't have a lot of management
strategies for these and even if we had
insecticides they're very difficult to
difficult to control
so that's all I have for the pest
groupings but I wanted to at least
mention pesticides before we wrap up
today
so I've repeated it with every pest
throughout the presentation but
pesticides are federally regulated
um the EPA has direct oversight of this
however individual states have been left
with the task of deciding what
pesticides can be applied to hemp
um or cannabis or marijuana crops if
that's what you're working in
um
you know there's a lot of
self-responsibility that comes here
which which can be very challenging if
you're a producer but you know the
biggest thing I can tell you is make
sure you're reading the label thoroughly
before you apply any product
and make sure it's feasible via label
language or a list put out by your state
for you to apply the product it's very
important and one other thing you could
do is kind of talk to your producer or
your buyer to see what opinions they may
have as far as products that you might
use or reply on the crop
um just I'm based in California I
thought that our league our language
regarding pesticide use was pretty
digestible and I thought I would at
least share what our situation is
um so this goes for cannabis or
marijuana in California
um you know if the active ingredients
found in the product are exempt from
tolerance residue tolerance requirements
and from registration so that would be
um designated as a 25 B insecticide or
pesticide
um or you know exempt from residue
tolerance requirements and use of the
product is not legally in conflict with
the label which I think is the more
important always making sure that
whatever you're using is not in legal
conflict with the label
and for hemp the only extra requirement
here is that you know the product is
actively registered for use on hemp and
what that might look like this is just a
product I know that has hemp on the
label you know this is the the name of
the product active ingredients here's
some label language regarding what crops
this product could be used in and you
know this is a situation where hemp is
explicitly on the label so as long as
this pesticide is registered in your
state and it's legal for use in your
state you can apply it to your hem
problem
um
so I thanks for participating and for
joining this talk today
um
as you've learned there are many species
that are observed in hemp some of them
are pests some of them are beneficials
and some of them are just feeding for a
little bit before they're moving on to
the next crop we've got some management
strategies and some knowledge at this
point but you know it's important to
remember that this is still a very new
crop even though it's been legal for
several years it's still very new
um in the American landscape and you
know as a
representative of a university you know
we're slowly making steps to conduct
more research with these things and as
we are able to conduct more research
we'll learn more management strategies
and we'll know better how to handle
these situations with more time and with
more experience
and the last thing I'll say is the most
important Cornerstone to managing pests
whether it's an insect or a Mite or a
pathogen or a weed is the economic
threshold so the economic value of your
crop determines every management
decision with him this is challenging
because the market is really unstable
and it's still developing and research
is ongoing so I'm hopeful that in the
years to come we'll have economic
thresholds for these pests in this crop
but it's still a work in progress
um so to close you know everything that
I said I think can be can be pretty much
found in this publication from a few
years ago and then author on this along
with colleagues from Colorado
um Tennessee and me in Virginia but this
is kind of the first stab we took at
explaining the situation
um kind of explaining the pest complex
and not just pest complex but other
things that you would see in the crop
um so I still think this is a paper
that's really helpful it's with the
Journal of integrated Pest Management
it's open access so if you find this
online you'll be able to read it I think
it's helpful and it kind of reiterates
what I said today
um another thing Whitney Crenshaw has
been
um basically an encyclopedia of
knowledge on this topic
um everything that I've learned from my
experience and my research can be
you know there's more information on
particular pests here so I would
encourage you to check out the Colorado
State hemp insect page for more
information on hemp insects and mites
and then lastly there's a million people
to thank for help with this but these
are just some I wanted to give a shout
out to Whitney like I said I'm Suzanne
Wainwright Evans the photo on the top
right and the photo in the top middle is
my postdoc advisor and Paulie Saul Alba
um
their their help
um and exposing me to issues that are
occurring in real time has been really
really really helpful so
um with that I am done and I'm happy to
um take any questions that might come so
we can check the chat and the Q a now
yeah it was a fantastic presentation
okay thank you you have several
questions in the Q a so feel free to
read them out loud
um okay the let's see the first thing I
see is research attached to
entomologists like Professor Chris
Carlton at LSU have claimed that
predatory mites have proved successful
against hemp russet mites and
cultivators have reported success using
species like cucamaris but this seems to
be contentious with other reports is
there research about this to be
published that is more conclusive
um at this time I don't know of anything
um and I I think I said it during the
hempress at my section when I was
talking but what we know so far is at
least the mites that are commercially
produced or not really working and
that's kind of what I know right now if
more information comes out you know I
would make sure it's from a reputable
Source
um like a peer-reviewed publication or
um you know something that's been
peer-reviewed so good question
um next question on average how many
eggs do the female corn ear worm lay it
appeared she deposited a single let
single egg in each location so
um she can lay a lot of eggs I'm not
sure of the exact value off the top of
my head but
um it's worth noting that she does lay
eggs singly so one at a time Wherever
She lays them but she can lay multiple
in a night
um what type of application for the corn
ear worm insecticide can I use it in my
drip system or foliar that's a great
question
um so any product that's currently
labeled
um for use in hemp is going to be a
foliar type of application
um with systemic or drip
insecticides I believe those are more
systemic and you know nothing like that
at least at this current point is
labeled for use in him so it would be a
foliar type of application and it's
worth noting as well that um
a lot of the products labeled for hemp
are biological in nature so they have a
biological active ingredient or they're
more organic production type of products
um which kind of means that they don't
have a strong residual effect so
anything that you apply is going to need
to be continuously applied you can't
just apply it once and be done
um let's see you say cannabis aphid only
feeds on cannabis what do you mean by
feed Dr punya nachapa has shown that the
Cannabis aphid can spread viruses to
potato through feeding they do feed on
other plants perhaps they are not able
to complete their life cycle on other
plants Aaron thinks that's a really
great Point
um you're entirely correct I get used to
saying things one way and this is what I
need to kind of help me remember to say
them the right way
um yes out of punya's lab there is a
paper showing that cannabis aphid can
transmit potato virus why to potatoes so
it can feed on potatoes to transmit this
virus however you're exactly right
that's a better way to say it um
it's not that it exclusively feeds on
cannabis crops it's that it needs
cannabis crops to complete its life
cycle and develop and continue its life
cycle so good thanks for pointing that
out
um does neem oil have insecticidal
qualities or does it work more like a
horticultural oil
um neem definitely has insecticidal
qualities
um our other Leaf Hoppers a problem in
the eastern U.S so things we've seen so
far are potato Leaf Hopper
that's the only one I I know of
specifically there can be other species
um but
as far as transmitting viruses like beet
curly top virus from beet Leaf Hopper I
am not sure I just know that it's not as
much of a frequent problem in the
eastern United States as beat Leaf
Hopper is to the Western United States
if that makes sense
um Aaron again are there sulfur products
allowed for use on hemp as an
insecticide I think that is a question
where it's going to depend on products
allowed for use from state to state
um
I I don't even want to say what states
may allow it because I'm not sure but I
I believe I've seen it on some
state-specific lists
um again if not sulfur then consider a
type of oil product which may also be on
a state-specific list
um I'll reiterate again it anytime you
apply a product or you're uncertain
about its legality or potential for use
in a hemp or cannabis crop I would
consult
um your County Extension agent in
California your County Agricultural
commissioner
resources like that who could give you a
more direct answer than I could
um have you evaluated till versus
no-till cultivation as a way to mitigate
rice root Nathan infestation that's a
good question so
I you know till versus no-till would be
more of an outdoor type of situation
um it can exist Outdoors but I don't
think it's as big of a problem Outdoors
so I'm not like I don't know that
um
this would be something to explore with
right rice root aphid at the current
time
um until or unless it becomes a greater
problem Outdoors
um Aaron again thanks Aaron you're
asking awesome questions
um with him being federally legal my
understanding is that pesticides are
regulated federally by the EPA and not
at a state level when you talk about
State differences are you talking about
high THC cannabis
um
yes and no I guess
hemp is a federally legal crop now
um
but I no that's a good question maybe
state-specific use isn't as as big of a
deal anymore since it is federally legal
and products are either going to have it
on the label or not but a lot of that is
because it takes
like it takes so much time to alter the
language on a pesticide label and I know
that companies have to go through
a lot of Hoots to get hemp added so
maybe for that reason States may still
have some type of state-specific use
list for him
um but that's definitely a thing for
high THC cannabis like you're asking um
which is what I was referring to with
the sulfur question earlier so
um the ultimate conclusion I can give is
that it just depends always no matter
what
um
can you discuss incidences of microbial
insecticides causing inflorescences to
fail compliance testing in ways in which
cultivators and you utilize these
controls while maintaining compliance
that's a great question
um I have heard stories of this
happening
um I don't you know I don't have a
specific story I guess I've heard
um
you know a situation where someone has
told me they know of Growers that this
has happened to
um
it can definitely happen my suggestion
would be
um you know if you can afford it maybe
testing a small section or testing a
couple buds before doing a complete
Harvest
um or you know applying it in enough
time that the microbial presence may be
reduced by the time you harvest the crop
that's that's the best advice I can give
there
and the last question can sulfur
products affect pH I do not know the
answer to that
um
Luis I don't know if you have any ideas
on that but that's I do not know and I
guess I should say I think there's
different schools of thought whether um
sulfur or Oils may do better at managing
russet mites on hemp
um a lot of it depends on experience and
who you're talking to and
um experience
so that that's all I can offer right now
um but thanks for the questions these
were all really good Aaron thanks for
for all the great questions I hope the
explanations were helpful
yeah thank you Katie thank you everyone
for joining us today uh
and yeah also fantastic uh presentation
Katie and as well as a q a
uh so everyone please join us in two
weeks April 5th for our sixth Square
winner focus on hemp pathogens so
yeah thank you everyone
thank you Katie yeah thanks
awesome okay yeah I um most people have
left but someone asked another question
it was just kind of a comment saying
that yeah it's a really good point
states can and do put more restrictive
use on pesticides than the federal
oversight States like California New
York and Florida do so regularly yeah
that's an excellent point
um it's not always more liberal than the
federal Viewpoint sometimes it's more
strict so good point okay
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu